hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the final round of
the ancient rapid preliminaries and it
is also one of great importance Arjun
already pretty much qualified but Anisha
definitely I should not lose if he wants
to qualify for the main event uh
otherwise uh someone else might qualify
instead of him now let's check out the
game it's quite an enjoyable one Arjun
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to D4 we have Knight to F6 by Anish
Bishop to F4 and now Pawn to D5 with E3
going again for a sort of a London
system setup Pawn to C5 and Knight to F3
we have Knights the C6 the London system
is now fully operational Knight beat the
D2 and now Knight the H5 going after the
bishop on F4 so Bishop to E5 and now
Pawn to E6 we have found the C4 and now
C captures on D4 so all been played
before nothing new here C captures on D5
with Queen captures and D5 and now
Bishop the C4 developing with Tempo
attacking the black queen queen back to
d8 and now there are two games that
reach this position one is Daniel dubo
versus Levon arunyan where the bishop
captures on D4 was played in the other
one is nihal sarin versus uh uh board
and Daniel the ark were also Bishop
captures and D4 was played and the both
of them ended in the draw but here Arjun
decided to try something else he plays
ecatra Sandy for instead and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game that's okay Anish continues
developing Bishop to E7 we have Queen to
E2 and now Anish Castle's King side and
while you might be expecting Castle's
kingside from Arjun that's exactly the
opposite of what he does he castles
Queen side we have Bishop to D7 and now
King to B1 getting the king away from
the C file a nice prophylactic move we
have Rook the C8 and now Bishop back to
G3 now you don't mind of course if
Knight captures on G3 because then each
captures and you get a nice open or
rather semi-open file for your rook and
here Anisha has uh a couple of options
uh options he could go for uh Knight day
five you could attack the bishop he
could reintroduce this Knight into the
game maybe shifted over to D5 but he
goes for the immediate attack with Pawn
to B5 a straight out Pawn sacrifice just
to open up lines in front of the white
king So Bishop captures on B5 and now
Knight to B4 putting pressure on the
bishop also preparing Queen to A5 to go
after the A2 Pawn so that's why Arjun
brings the bishop back on now Guard the
guard the A2 pawn and now Pawn to E5
another Pawn Sacrifice by a niche uh to
open up lines towards the white king now
Bishop to F5 is coming with a deadly
check so here at Knight captures an E5
uh he he accepts the pawn sacrifice and
now Bishop the f 5 width check and
there's really no good Square for the
king I will just uh a lot okay middle
just left himself in the room that never
happened uh but okay after Bishop to F5
uh you have to play something if you
play King the C1 uh that's a problem
Knight captures an A2 is is mating one
and that's all there is I think there's
a bit of an echo now that might open the
door let me just close the door
all right so uh obviously that's not
gonna work and uh yes the bishop is spin
the bishop cannot capture the Knight so
that would be a terrible mistake for
Arjun also King the A1 doesn't really
help because then you have Knight the
seed to check with all sorts of nasty uh
discoveries from the bishop now like
maybe not capture Sandy for winning the
queen and that's just game so instead
after Bishop to F5 we have knighted the
E4 this is the only reasonable option
for uh for Arjun and now Knight the F6
piling up on the Knight on e4 we have
Pawn to F3 defending the Knight and the
now Queen to B6 Anish brings the queen
into the attack uh we have Rook H to E1
getting the Rook into the game as well
and now Knight F the D5 and all of the
pieces are now coming for the white king
and here we have Bishop back to B3
interestingly in this complete mess of a
position A3 is winning for Arjun but
it's not a move you would play in a
position like this because you have to
calculate all sorts of knights the C3
check ideas with the Knight here being
pinned by the bishop on F5 and although
it doesn't work it's it's a bit too much
for example I can give you one line that
starts with with A3 if you try something
like Knight to C3 check it's okay to
capture and now let's say Knight the D5
opens up a discovery here Queen blocks
with Queen to B2 never go play Knight
captures on C3 Fork the king and the
rook and after King the A1 now you can
capture The Rook Knight captures and the
one Queen capture Sun B6 a captures and
Rook cap for sun D1 and you would get a
position uh like this where okay you
have uh you have two pieces for the for
the Rook but it's uh you know completely
completely crazy stuff white would be
winning here but you have to find this
in a rapid game Bishop to B3 was played
by Arjun and now Anish gets the option
of playing this beautiful Rook to C3
move uh The Rook of course cannot be
captured uh the Knight can't move the
Knight is still pinned and if you
capture with the beep on now Knight
captures here uh captures the the White
Queen it would still be very tricky
white has a lot of material for that
Queen but still uh you you do not want
to play this so I have to Rook the C3
what Arjun has to do is play Knights the
C4 go after the black queen this way and
this also guards the A5 Square which is
why it's very important he played Knight
to D7 instead attacking the rook and the
queen hoping that at the bishop capture
so then the Knight will be unpinned and
the Knight can capture on C3 but this
way he allows Anish to bring the queen
to A5 so Queen to A5 now
with some very nasty ideas of
eliminating the defender of the A2 Pawn
the bishop on B3 and then just you know
completely crashing through the position
so now Bishop captures on D5 and now
before capturing the bishop Anish plays
this Rook the C2 move idea being that
okay now we're gonna capture the queen
also we can capture the the pawn on A2
next uh sorry the bishop and then the
pawn on A2 next but Arjun doesn't allow
it because whatever he plays loses the
game unless he plays Queen captures on
C2 and that's exactly what he does so
Queen captures on C2 Knight captures and
the now King captures on C2 with Bishop
captures on D7 and now as the bishop is
still hanging Bishop back to B3 and we
have this position where a niche has a
queen but Arjun has a knight and a rook
for that Queen so it's a really really
crazy position uh let's see how how they
play it out we have Bishop to B4 by
Anish you could bring the Rook into the
game but it's not all that impressive
the king will just go to B1 so instead
he tries uh Bishop to B4 first puts
pressure on The Rook here Rook to E3 and
now Queen to B6 now not allowing the
pawn to start advancing as The Rook on
E3 will be hanging so King to B1 and now
Pawn to A5 and it seems like Anish did
everything now A4 is coming A3 is coming
if he can get the pawn to A3 uh he
should be winning this uh at this game
so here Knight the C3 and now okay the
A4 Pawn a dfr square is covered so you
can play for just yet Rook the C8
bringing the Rook into the attack Knight
the D5 now attacking the queen and now
we have Bishop to F5 with check and this
is where uh things started to go wrong
for a niche the way to deal with this
position is to go Queen to G6 check
as you want your Bishop on D7 uh
guarding the A4 square and now once the
king moves now you strike with A4 and
okay you you give up the bishop and B4
but you you capture the bishop and B3
and now it seems like this shouldn't be
enough because of Rook captures on B3
but there's Bishop A4 now and now white
will lose um uh a lot of material so if
you don't have Rook captures on B3 it's
hard to define the move that works so if
you play A3 that doesn't really look
like
um something you want to do it's
weakening the Kings
the queen side and uh yeah it would be
it would be great for a niche however
after Knight to D5 Bishop to F5 check
was played and now you're just uh gonna
be down a tempo for for the rest of the
game King to a one and now you can't
push the pawn you can't play A4 so here
Queen day seven and each wants to play
it but not just Knight captures on B4 a
captures on B4 and now Bishop to D6
preparing Bishop to C5 uh cutting off
the queen The Rook from the C file and
that's pretty much all the counter play
that Anish had with Queen to B6 Bishop
to C5 attacking the queen and now Queen
to G6 uh here with with Queen to B8 you
can still fight this but it's a very
very hard to uh to see why because uh
the Bishops here are controlling these
squares so of course you know that the
opponent will start marching forward but
after Queen to G6 it's just much much
easier for the pawn to start marching
forward here we have rooked the E7
claiming another Square for the white
Pawn now you have these three squares
covered and once the pawn reaches D7
then it's only a matter of of a rook
check or whatever you know depending on
what black plays so and also the F7 Pawn
is hanging so you're just threatening to
pick up the queen here so Bishop to E6
and each blocks this and now Pawn to D5
the pawn starts marching forward Bishop
to F5 Now Pawn to D6 and now
uh you see the problem here uh here if
uh the queen was on B8 in that position
where we said that Queen to be it would
be better than Queen to G6 you could
just pick up the bishop now you can't
pick up the bishop uh because you just
get checkmated Rook D1 will be mate in
one so here Rook the f8 by a niche I
have the the defend the F7 Pawn but now
just Pawn to D7 and he was in this
position unmove 38 that Anish giri
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here whatever you play
uh you're just gonna lose a lot of
material yeah for example if H5 it's
it's a matter of just queening the pawn
not much to a rook captures Rook
captures or even better Bishop captures
and F7 check uh eliminates all the
material from the board and gives white
a completely winning position now you
capture The Rook with check now if you
don't want to give up the queen for free
you play something like Queen of f8 Rook
characters King characters and now you
just finish by grabbing the bishop as
well check King
Rook captures on F5 that's all there is
to it and if you don't want to do that
you could give up the bishop for the
past Pawn but still Rook E Capture sund7
now you're just down too much material
it's two Bishops and a rook for for a
queen uh that's just not gonna work if
let's say Rook the E8 you can play Rook
d8 and that's it if Queen C6 guarding
the Rook there's even Rook one to D7 and
now the Rook is no longer guarded you
can't capture because of Checkmate and
here you would just resign or you have
to give up the queen and then Rook
captures luckily after Rook D1 check you
have uh Rook to D1 so it's not a
Checkmate uh and there's nothing for
black to do here so of course Anish all
of this and after and after Pawn to D7
and move 38 it was in this position that
he resigned the game
uh so yeah brilliant stuff by by both of
them brilliant game by Anisha just uh I
I really enjoyed both of the pawn
sacrifices here it um
uh the Ponte B5 was really really
spectacular just you know opening up the
the files for attack and then right
after that pawn to E5 giving up that
pawn uh to to give Bishop to F5 check
and it was just a beautiful beautiful
attack uh something that uh you know I I
just enjoy seeing um uh and I'm sure you
guys do as well uh but Arjun just uh you
know there there's no there's that uh
saying I think Paul Karis maybe said it
or or someone like there's uh like
there's nothing like uh like like a good
stubborn defense or something like that
but yeah yeah here Arjun was just able
to put up a really really stubborn and
sturdy defense and uh yeah at some point
Anish was uh just the doomed uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
here are the standings and the the final
eight so uh those who qualified for the
main event are young she used to do that
with 28 points he wins first place then
with 27 we have three people go
basically Magnus Crossing in fifth place
with 26 another back up to satro who was
leading the tournament for the first
three days on 23. Richard rapper with 22
and David Gujarati with 21 points and as
you can see Anish did not qualify
because he lost this game to Arjun Anish
dropped to 20 points already he remained
on 20 points and divided overtook a
niche and he qualified for the main
event and now vidit will face the winner
Yang sheast of Duda in the quarterfinals
so uh uh others who didn't qualify uh so
Vincent kymer David Anton Daniel Daniel
nardisky Hare Krishna Eric Henson Aditya
metal and Niels grandelius and who will
face who in the quarterfinals Avid will
face Yankees to do the Rapport will face
will face Shakir mamijarov and the
Magnus Carlsen will face Arjun Erica
easy so a really interesting matches to
check out tomorrow
uh so yeah that's the game and a little
bit of info about who who's facing who
and who did uh well who did not do well
so hope you guys enjoyed that uh I would
uh wish a very happy birthday to dhanush
and a very happy birthday to pedrino uh
and I would also uh like to thank Lord
of Chess uh Anderson Vera and torko
stanquist for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event uh until it finishes so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day